allez on en vient à ce bras de fer à
présent entre la république en marché
une maison d'édition à cause d'un nom de
domaine le nom c'est en marche point de
point fr il est détenu par un éditeur
qui publie des bd de caricatures du
président emmanuel macron depuis
plusieurs mois maintenant et bien la
république en marche veut le récupérer
et on le comprend pour la campagne
présidentielle
a priori le problème aurait pu être
réglé rapidement sauf que dans son
courrier adressé à la maison d'édition
le parti présidentiel affirme également
je cite qu'il y a une volonté de
nuisance par l'affichage des images de
caricatures du président de la
république pour l'éditeur concerné il
s'agit bel et bien d'une volonté de
censure on va en parler justement
[Musique]
bonjour anthony roux bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être en direct avec nous sur
rt france alors vous êtes l'éditeur de
cette fameuse maison d'édition que s'est
il passé quel est donc ce bras de fer
entre cette bataille pour pour un nom de
domaine
ben alors c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui est vraiment très très belle parce
que
c'est une série qu'on a créée avec le
dessinateur allen parts depuis 2010 est
enfin qui retrace les quatre années du
quinquennat donc le premier le premier
ouvrage est sorti en 2010 9 à 6 jeu
et on a en a retracé chaque année du
quinquennat et un moment durant l'année
2000 2019 on s'est mis a plaisanté sur
qu'est ce qu'on fait voilà chaque année
du quinquennat 2022
on est 1 et 5
est-ce qu on part sur un tome 6 est ce
que est ce qu'il est une nouvelle série
que l'on va lancer et c'était plus une
plaisanterie et par rapport à ça très
rapidement j'ai fait un site vraiment
amateur ou où j'ai créé le nom de
domaine en marche 2022 avec la volonté
d'avoir quelque chose de ces parodique
sur 7 sur cette plaisanterie n'est
vraiment il n'y avait pas de patrons
menthe et de nuisances derrière c'est
évidemment ça fait partie de la liberté
de ton 1 voilà voilà c'est ça donc quand
même mis ça en place il y avait vraiment
on n'aurait pas imaginé les proportions
que ça a pu prendre juste derrière mais
même à ce que vous avez le contact et
donc par par la république en marche oui
me recontacter un biais d'un cabinet
d'avocats en décembre 2021 on a reçu un
mail de l'afnic dont qui gère toutes les
questions de noms de domaine avec un
dossier utiliser huit ou neuf pages
rédigé par un cabinet d'avocats
expliquant qu'un majorité présidentielle
souhaite enfin souhaite mais exige de
récupérer dans le domaine
quand on avait
alors le terrain excellent c'était
vraiment faire danser les gens
disons que ce n'était pas cette mails ne
s'était pas est-ce que vous pouvez nous
le rendre gracieusement où que ce soit a
priori il avait pas le nom était en 2019
il en était disponible
donc
ils disent on ils n'ont pas voulu jouer
la carte du bambin ils ont ils ont su
retrouver pour un loyer le dossier
ils pouvaient très simplement de passer
un simple coup de fil
en décembre 2021 en expliquant la
problématique et ça ce serait réglé
c'était très facilement l'aurait pas
bataillé or elle va dire avant dans le
gard ne coûte que coûte
finalement mais en toute franchise je
n'aurais même pas monnayé j'aurais
laissé gracieusement et là maintenant on
voulait plus
j'ai pas envie de laisser jéhovah disons
que je vais laisser la flic décidé pour
voir jusqu'où jusqu'où les choses
peuvent aller s'il advenait que donne
raison à la république en marche ou à
nous après si la venue de dhiba vous
devez le rendre on leur rendra n'est pas
de y'a pas de problème par rapport à ça
on va pas partir dans les grandes
procédure judiciaire pour une blague
demander plus et c'est cette attaque
justement sur les caricatures à quelles
formes telles prises concrètement
alors donc dans le dossier et le
colonisé le dossier fait à peu près huit
mois page
parce qu'ils ont mis quelques visuels
dedans donc ils ont mis des visuels des
albums et surtout il ya certains propos
qui nous ont vraiment choqué j'en cite
un par exemple à une activité de
diffusion d'ouvragés dans l'objet unique
et de porter atteinte à la réputation de
la hem et de monsieur emmanuel macron en
tant que président de la république
donc ça veut dire que les mais dès que
l'on fait ces bd la plus
particulièrement ont pour objet unique
de porter atteinte au président de la
république est là on est clairement sur
une attaque à la caricature et à la
parodie non dans le contexte que l'on
connaît sur les caricatures qui sont un
sujet extrêmement sensible
ça vous fait d'autant plus réagir que le
gouvernement s'en prennent à vous
oui puis surtout c'est la cohérence
entre le discours officiel et ce qui se
passe en coulisses
parce que ce soit le dessinateur enfin
le volant de personnes vraiment ouverte
au dialogue
on aurait pas aujourd'hui on n'aurait
pas coûte que coûte dans une phase
d'opposition dix ans maintenant le garde
pas y'a pas tergiverser mais on a même
tenté plusieurs appels du pied notamment
sur les réseaux en alertant en
en
mettant des petites ailes ou près des
demandes de la majorité du d'un comité
local enfin on a vraiment voulu board
irb a regardé ce qui se passe mais venez
nous parler on peut en discuter vous
êtes obligés de passer par un cabinet
d'avocats en plus c'est une procédure
qui est payante je reprends le signaler
on a su que cette procédure coûte et
déjà 250 euros 21 procédures et je doute
que le cabinet d'avocats soit bénévoles
en plus donc c'est c'est un peu c'est
une dépense d'argent qui serait mieux
ailleurs par conséquent tant que si
j'imagine pour vous maison des blocs
pour l'instant et je touche du poêlon là
rien en arrière les déboursés
heureusement l'ouverture de la procédure
ne déclenche pas des frais de notre côté
heureusement et parce qu'aussi j'ai fait
le choix de répondre à la vni qu au
moins même gpu et biner d'avocats enfin
voila c je suis resté
on gère la main terme il reste patent du
coup à ce que ce que vous avez arrêté ou
est-ce que vous continuez finalement
laissé ses parutions
alors les parutions continue la sortie
de tom qu'être les peu de temps et on
est bien entendu en train de travailler
sur le tome 5 qui se terminera par
l'élection présidentielle on restera sur
la logique de la couverture totale du
quinquennat merci beaucoup on va suivre
cela merci beaucoup c'est que libéraux
de nous avoir expliqué ce problème en
direct ce matin sur rtl